it's been six months since the death of
george floyd and the global protest that
followed
we've already had the topple statues and
the black squares on social media
tonight once again we focus on race and
revolution
and ask will britain change
[Music]
good evening i'm jillian joseph over the
next hour we'll discuss whether the uk
has made any concrete
progress towards eradicating racism
joining us criminal barrister alexandra
wilson who founded
women in law and was recently mistaken
for a defendant
three times in the same day in court
also on the panel the author of everyone
versus racism
patrick hutchinson who went viral after
carrying a far-right protester
to safety chichiwanuku
founder of europe's first professional
majority black and minority ethnic
orchestra also joins us along
with lord simon woolley founder of
operation black vote
and chair of the race disparity units
advisory board
until last year facing then a live
virtual studio audience from around the
country they'll be sharing their
experiences of whether attitudes have
changed
in the uk and proposing solutions
well we've had commitments from the
government and major corporations alike
tonight we ask whether 2020 will be the
year
this country changes the way it thinks
about race
if we're not gonna listen we're gonna
scream louder and louder and we're not
gonna start
until something is done people will
speak up about it and be like you know
what that's wrong what you're doing
it's not a moment it's something that's
fundamental people aren't chatting
they are citizens and they have rights
what i really hope is that people just
learn to respect each other because
everyone's going through stuff you don't
have to look far to hear from families
who've lost loved ones
to covid19 i didn't think something like
this was capable of taking him away
it's an interesting experience being
stopped by the police you create an
environment
where you create animosity
[Applause]
have you experienced racism in the job
that you're in
of course if i don't understand and
accept that anger
who am i i think it's time we stopped
our cringing
embarrassment about our history about
our traditions
and about our culture
it has sparked change but it's really
important that
it's not
[Music]
and people be positive and accept who we
are and
who you want to be we want the black
community
to be one this is what we're fighting
for we've got the same features like
everybody else
it's just our skin color is different
[Music]
images and voices from the past six
months
amongst them athletes kneeling in
support of black lives matter
the sport has been at the forefront of
this global protest movement
but here in the uk it's the sector with
the most visible problem with diversity
especially at the top take football
the premier league doesn't have a single
black owner
chair or chief executive amongst its
ranks
and together the governing bodies for
football rugby
cricket tennis golf athletics and
cycling
have one black board member between them
last month 40 clubs signed up to the
football association's new
diversity code and committed to making
sure
10 of their senior coaches are non-white
here's former england footballer leanne
sanderson
on how her sport has changed one thing
that really stands out for me is the
lack of black players
and ethnic minority players in the
women's top league and if you look at
you know the starting elevens if you
look at the squads there's definitely
lacking somewhere
we have to look at why that is the case
and i think what's happened in the last
six months
companies organizations teams are now
thinking actually
well hold on a minute here we're not
really giving equal opportunity
what do you think is preventing more
players like yourself from taking up
management roles and going into that
that area of football
you know i think it's almost support as
well you know and the encouragement to
get involved in those roles i think
you know we have all these plans and
there's always talk about these
five-year plans ten-year plans and stuff
like that but
i think it should be a no-brainer that
you know everybody's given an
opportunity
do you think that anything has changed
since the the killing of george floyd
i'm definitely seeing a lot more people
that have woken up during this time
which is fantastic to see
and we must continue the conversation
and for me you know
i don't think it's good to divide and
conquer i think we must unite and
everybody's trying to hopefully
work towards the same goal and that's
all of us being equal and hopefully one
day
i'll live in a world where that'll be
the case
former england international leanne
sanderson calling for more support for
players
wanting to make that transition into
leadership
and that's a good place to start the
need for more people from diverse
backgrounds in decision-making positions
whether it be in sport or in business
first up from the audience is
samantha wright and samantha's the chair
of the city of london's black
asian and minority ethnic network
samantha what would you like to say
the representation of bame and senior
roles is my newt
lower level employees don't have any
similarities or roles to inspire to all
protected characteristics are
underrepresented
across the higher employment structures
therefore salaries for black and
minority staff in a professional
capacity
is lower at all levels ethnicity
reported data reflects this
equality still needs to be addressed
this hasn't been changed
samantha thank you well highlighting
there the imbalance in many businesses
which uh she rightly says
is backed up by the data
percent of the 3.7 million management
jobs
in the private sector are held by black
leaders
the confederation of british industry is
now calling on the uk's biggest firms
to appoint at least one racially and
ethnically diverse board member
by the end of 2021
since october six ftse 102 ftse 250
companies
have pledged to do so let's
take this to the panel and simon wooley
are
visa schemes necessary is it necessary
to enforce on companies
that they have ethnically diverse boards
well we've had a conversation like no
other because this has been a year like
no other
in many ways we've had a double a double
global pandemic
covert 19 and its devastating impact on
black asian and minority ethnic
communities and
and the death of george floyd and in
many ways it's convulsed
many of our nations in particular the uk
to to look at ourselves and say you know
what on so many levels
in so many areas race inequality
persists
and as you have highlighted particularly
at that senior level
in in sport and in business and in
politics
never before in my lifetime as have i
known
so many white people that have actually
begun to look through a black
lives lens and said
something is profoundly wrong and
we collectively must do something about
it now
that's a great opportunity i i just
sincerely hope that we seize it
and it just doesn't become a moment but
becomes a momentum
in which we can both transform our
society
our businesses uh our sporting
arenas but above all offer hope
hope that if you have the talent you can
go from a
to b to success now it's a start
and it's a conversation like we've never
had i just hope that it continues
okay alexandra uh the cbi's race ratio
is that the type of scheme that you
think's necessary should these things be
enforced or should they evolve naturally
i certainly think that they should be
enforced i think for too long we've been
waiting
for these these changes to happen
naturally organically and they're just
not happening i mean i see the same
patterns
in my area which is law at the senior
level you
only 1.1 of qcs are black
only 1.1 of judges are black
that's not good enough and actually the
organic way of you
slowly encouraging people to apply is
just not working
and that for me is because there are
institutional barriers in the way
ultimately when you have a profession or
when you have an industry that
all of the senior people or the majority
of the senior people come from a certain
type of background
that is always going to be a barrier to
new people entering and so i think we
need to do more about it and personally
i do think that we need to set targets
okay panel for the moment thank you uh
let's hear now from one company flexing
its muscles over diversity in the
boardroom
the uk's biggest fund manager legal and
general investment management
recently warned ftse 100 companies with
all white boards
that any failure to diversify leadership
teams after 2022
could have implications for future
investment here's senior fund manager
justin onware kusu what elgin has said
is that they will vote down the chair of
the nominee committee the nominee
the nomination committee the nomination
committee actually selects the directors
onto the board
or they'll vote down the chair of the
board if companies have failed
to meet that challenge studies show that
ethnically diverse boards
tend to have more inclusive cultures and
therefore tend to have
stronger financial and investment
results
so one company trying to drive through
change at the highest levels there
to the audience now and i'd like to take
just a show of hands from you
how many of you have noticed a change
at your place of work maybe your
company's now setting targets
or offering more training if that's the
case please put your hand up for me
not many very many of you probably say
less than
less than a third of you there saying
that there have been any changes
in their place of work well let's stay
with the audience we'll take two
questions now
on possible solutions first to asha
prower in west sussex who's a
construction project
manager at gatwick airport
um my question is government legislation
mandates that companies with 250 or more
employees
must publish their gender pay gap data
do you think that we will see equal
visibility and legislation put in place
regarding ethnicity pay gap reporting
thank you asha and to uh michael
barrington hibbett
who's chief executive of the recruitment
company barrington hibbett associates
we're going to hear from him in a second
we've just got to get michael up there
but let's go straight to the panel on
that question
as to whether we will see uh diversity
uh targets
uh in terms of pay um chichi what do you
think
in terms of the ethnicity pay gap does
it exist first of all has that been your
experience
not in my industry in the classical
music industry
everybody is on the there's we have
rules and regulations for
every single part of the orchestra um
that is
absolutely equal regardless of gender or
ethnicity
and so that doesn't yet well hopefully
hopefully it never will
apply to the classical music industry
uh patrick hutchinson if we can just
bring you in there
um is this something that that you're
aware of that there is a disparity
between that the pay of uh
black people in employment and their
white counterparts
yeah hi um i would say definitely um
when i was working in uh
in the city in the corporate arena um
i used to have discussions regularly
with my
my fellow work colleagues and we found
that um
on several occasions i i was paid less
along with
some of my asian colleagues less than my
white counterparts
so it definitely exists it's not a
fallacy it's something that definitely
exists out there
especially i would say in the corporate
world
let's uh go back to uh michael
barrington hibbett now who's chief
executive of the recruitment company
barrington hibbett associates um glad
we've got you uh back there michael um
let us know your question
thank you julian i know from firsthand
experience that black professionals with
ethnically
sounding names will see far fewer
approaches
when it comes to senior level
appointments
blind cvs have been touted as a solution
but i personally feel it doesn't address
the underlying
systemic issues can i answer the panel
particularly lord wooly who has done so
much to increase diversity
in politics what they feel the solutions
are
okay thank you lord wooly your name is
on that one
what what do you think the solutions are
mentioned there perhaps not putting
names on cvs that might be a potential
route to equality
what were two points to the to the
former question look
when i was chair of the race disparity
unit i convinced the prime minister
theresa may to
undergo the ethnic minority pay gap
uh review and she agreed
that legislation is on the shelf and it
needs to be
implemented as a matter of urgency once
you lay bear the disparities
you can see the work that you need to do
but you know in regards to what are the
solutions we
have to have a culture change and the
starting point of the culture change is
that for every business for every
football team for every
you want the best you want to play the
best you want to be the most effective
the most creative and what we do know is
that diversity gives you that creativity
that talent so
you know this is not a tick box exercise
this is not political correctness gone
mad
actually if we want to turbo charge
britain plc
then we need to ensure all our talent
has pathways to reach the success and i
think when you start
from that point how do we be better
how do we be more creative more
effective
then you roll back and say okay this is
not just because we want black people to
do but to do this and that
we want our companies to be more dynamic
and i think that would be a greater
driver than saying
can you do us a favor no do yourself a
favor
unleash talent alexandria you're nodding
there
is that the case that companies actually
should do themselves a favor because
actually it's
going to increase productivity the more
diverse workforce that they have
absolutely i think that for too long
companies haven't seen the value in
diversity and i completely echo what
lord willie has said
it's not just about ticking boxes and i
think that
once we start to really value and
appreciate
what a diverse workforce looks like and
and the benefits that come with that you
know often there is a business case for
having more diversity
particularly in again my industry i know
that
there are lots of reasons why you might
want to have a diverse range of
barristers or solicitors
quite probably one of the most important
is that clients expect it
you know clients are actually expecting
to see people that look like them
whether that's in
you know family or criminal law or even
corporate and commercial or people want
to see people
that look like them and actually
that in and of itself is a good enough
reason for all companies to
to start looking to diversify their
workforce
okay thank you panel so we've heard
about the the changes being worked on at
boardroom level
and some proposed solutions from the
audience mandatory reporting
of the ethnicity pay gap and keeping cvs
anonymous for example
but has there been a shift in the way
individuals think
about racism let's go back to the
audience uh
and to janet walker this time chair of
anti-racist
cumbria janet what are your thoughts
so for me it's when we see black
families on adverts
and the racist fallout is barely
noticeable because it's the norm
we'll start to see a change in culture
in thinking
and in attitudes when no one bats an
eyelid
when black or police officers walk the
beat or when the book of prize is won by
a black poet
and the journalists don't need feel the
need to include black
in the description of that individual we
will know that there's been a culture
change and that it's starting to happen
when we see a boardroom table that is
rich in diversity
not just women but colour trans
disability
that's when we'll start to know there's
been a change
janet thank you for your contribution
janet referring there to some of the
negative responses to a sainsbury's
advert
showing a black family celebrating
christmas let's play a short clip
i just really hope i can see you me too
i've literally
i cannot stop thinking about mum's
roasties
what about my gravy what about your
gravy hey
you was
[Music]
how does mum put up with you your gravy
is pretty good to be fair and i just
really want to be home for it
so my gravy is the best honey she says
so a perfectly normal advert featuring a
perfectly normal black
family nothing to report there right
wrong i'll read just a few of the
complaints made
on twitter where are the british people
i'm dreaming of a white christmas or
even
you may as well rename yourself
blackberries
panel chichi first of all to you were
you surprised by some of those
responses there were thousands of
responses on on social media
oh it's of course i mean it's just
alarming and
and distressing to to think that um
you know still the visual aspect of
anyone and anything
goes before before even saying
hearing a single word from anybody um
it's it's
it's deeply distressing and
i i think the way
these things end up being like this is
it's all
passed down you know from parents
through generations
and the the reason why my
organization is has had the success
it has and why we are free to to make
these steps forward is because
i simply started from scratch five years
ago with the chineke orchestra
and so we right from the very beginning
it was black led
board management people on the stage the
music we play
completely diverse from dead white men's
music
to living black composers and and
we've we've had to jump through various
hoops to prove ourselves but now
that we have we have we
we are also demonstrating inclusion and
how it works and we have
leading members from some of the top
orchestras in our country
wanting to be side by side with us in
our orchestra
and i just think we just need to have a
better more open and free
dialogue between people i don't think
it's it
somehow shoving a you know putting
having an advertisement with just a
black family it's going to wind people
up we know that
i think we need to demonstrate um
inclusivity across the board from top to
bottom in
every possible way that we can i mean
the advert was one in a series there
were other families that were portrayed
as well but patrick one of the
the tweets described the advert as
absolutely
sickening how does that make you feel
well funny enough i actually posted this
same advert on my
instagram page because i was uh you know
i i was quite upset about the responses
that were um
that i'd seen and i wanted to get the uh
you know the responses from the people
that followed me and you know we were
all in
agreeance that it was just an absolute
disgrace i mean
i loved the the you know the center of
attention that the black father
you know being a black father myself and
i love the uh the old school
the old school word you know
cinematography about the advert
and i can't i i it beggars belief how
people can find that
um distasteful and i and i just
wonder like where we're going to get to
a place where
you know i don't see any complaints when
there's a white family on on every
single advert you know most of the time
you don't see anything
because we don't have a problem with
things like that so why is it that when
there's a black family on tv
you know and you don't see that too
often you know if you haven't got
anything good to say why not just be
quiet
you know but i just feel it's a disgrace
and it didn't shock me i'll add
as well yeah panel uh nodding in an
agreement there
and patrick there's certainly those in
society um who aren't in favor shall we
say of multiculturalism
um and something that you know we want
to to bring in play when you attended
that black lives matter protest
and you hoisted up a gentleman certain
gentleman to safety
later turned out that he was a far-right
supporter
what did you feel when you you learnt
that that detail
um i i to be honest it didn't change
anything about
uh about what i did and i would do it
again i would
i would rescue or try to help anybody in
need
because i i don't see color i see a
human being
first and foremost and i you know i'm
not going to be party to
you know anyone's demise just stand
there when i know that i'm capable of
doing something about it
regardless of what they might think of
me
patrick thank you very much honest uh
response there let's bring in that
rachel a student from limington in
hampshire rachel what's your question
hello um so with the understanding that
change happens
one person at a time do you feel that
now is the time for us to become less
passive as individuals
when we do acknowledge our powers and
individuals to create change
and you know we take absolute
responsibility for that change ourselves
what's the first and most important
thing that each of us can do
to ensure that there's a future where
being british means we're part of a true
um a truly equal and fair society
and where that disgraceful backlash
um doesn't happen as it did towards the
sainsbury's
birth rachel thank you for your question
uh rachel they're asking i suppose what
allies can do what can white people do
to help
eradicate racism alexandra
i think that there are two things and i
know i was asked for the first thing but
i think there are two things that you
can do
i think the first the first is educate
yourself
we all have a responsibility to make
sure that we are alive to these issues
be to be honest being silent not
making that effort to to learn more
about racism and
britain's role in in race relations for
you know for hundreds of years
to be honest it's just not excusable
anymore it's so accessible we have the
internet there are so many good books
there are so many good documentaries
so that's the thing that we can do on an
individual level
um but i also think that you need to
look at on a community level
and how can white people or even other
black people be
the most supportive they can call it out
when you see it
don't just you know pretend you didn't
hear it don't
leave black people to fight all of the
battles actually if you see something
that's racist if you hear something
that's racist
if you even suspect it to be you know
call it out speak to that person
address it and that's how things will
actually start to change
thank you uh let's go to zen adai from
nottingham
uh you want to talk about the role of
social media
yeah really just because i think after
the issue
with george floyd earlier this year we
noticed the massive rise
in activism on social media and i think
that
instagram activism just indirectly
trivializes issues of race
so my question to the panel really is
shouldn't we stop
applauding our peers for merely
reposting an infographic
on their story rather than educating
themselves to a higher level
because at this point aren't we just
praising fish for swimming
okay thanks zen and uh rachel making
points there about uh individual
responsibility and
performative activism before i bring in
the panel
um i'd be curious to see how many of
those in the audience and on the panel
as well in a moment have had
conversations about race
over the past six months
raise your hands for me if you've had a
conversation about
race over the last six months
uncomfortable or otherwise
pop your hands up for me
okay looks like nearly all of you have
had a conversation
about race uh uncomfortable or otherwise
um let's ask the panel now
who on the panels had a conversation
about race uncomfortable or otherwise in
the last six months
falling on from the killing of george
floyd all four hands up there
so uh we can see that definitely uh it
has been on
the agenda um simon wooley if we come to
you now
in terms of the questions that we'd
heard from the audience what
role has social media played um
is it has it just been a superficiality
i.e
just the the hashtag black lives matter
and people perhaps haven't done
anything further than that in terms of
activism
well it can be and it sometimes
sometimes it is
but other times it can be a galvanizing
force i mean you know i saw
patrick on social media with this
unbelievable act of humanity
he picked up a man who hates him who
probably wanted to do him home
and there he was he took him under his
wing
pulled him over his shoulder and says i
don't care if you hate me
i'm gonna protect you now that couldn't
have happened if it wasn't for social
media
and i think that we need to use the
tools to to educate ourselves and
the other thing too with social media
you know when we've seen these young men
and women black and white
pull down the the statues in my lifetime
again
we've never had such a conversation
about our history
now some seem to phrase it as a culture
war
others want to say let's have a
discussion let's see
what these people have contributed to
our society and let's see what they did
to humanity
and then we discuss it and on balance we
say yes
no maybe but never before have we known
so much about the uh these
individuals that were involved in the
enslavement of africans
and we've put them on a pedestal and
left them there
for centuries and now we're saying do we
really want to do that
so social media has its place but the
biggest factor julian and your panelists
will know this too
is is activism um as alexander said
push back make the plans tell people
it's in everyone's interest to have
these discussions to unleash
talent and for us to make a better
society
i would just say this that we have an
opportunity from the madness from the
awfulness
of of george floyd of covert to
look at our institution through a lens
that we've never been able to do before
and and in that moment we can really
fundamentally build back much better
this has given us that opportunity
chicha you put your hand up there you
wanted to come in
yes i did because i we've all been
all of us of course we want to take
action action does speak louder than
words
we've all been in lockdown so my my
children and my nephews and nieces
prevent wouldn't allow me to go out and
demonstrate because i said
mum you're too old and they all went out
and protested
but one of the things i did i the action
that i did i did i
i wrote a letter to the prime minister
when he started
talking about oh let's let's do another
fact-finding commission
i'm sorry boris johnson but we have so
many fact-finding commissions that have
already
hundreds of them and david lammy has
produced them and
you know we've had the mcpherson report
now is time to
implement we have all the facts we know
all the facts
let's just get on with it change is not
going to happen
unless we have the will and the support
of legislators
and politicians who also need to be held
accountable
to ensure that change is
written into law and and all the
accusations of racism are held up
against all the perpetrators and anyone
who's trying to
you know they con we were just going
round and round in circles of
trying to find excuses not to do
anything
alexandra you put your hand up as well
yes um i would echo everything that the
panel has already said lord willie and
chichi i completely agree
um the thing i wanted to add about
social media is that let's not
forget the dark side of social media too
i think that
i've certainly been someone who has um
fallen victim perhaps to racist abuse on
social media
and i do think that social media now
provides
this platform where people can hide
behind a screen
and say things that in real life you
know you would be charged
and you would as a criminal barrister
speaking you know you would
potentially be in in quite quite serious
trouble for
but when you're behind a screen with a
bot account you know a fake account
without your name
you get away with saying a lot more um
and i've certainly experienced that and
i know
colleagues and friends have experienced
that too and so i do think there's a
dark side of social media
i mean not only the bot accounts let's
think about some big
fairly famous people that have you know
tommy robinson
has really built up a platform on social
media
and i can't remember her name thank
goodness but the woman who's very
polarizing
and has been removed from social social
media multiple times he's made voices
i think we know who you mean i think you
know what i mean
i i've just remembered her name but i
don't even want to say it but um
i think i think um you know though
those sort of people have been given
huge platforms and social media
the social media sites themselves have
often acted far too slowly
in removing them from their platforms
and i think that that's something that
you know that's the kind of other side
of social media that we should also
bring into this discussion
okay panel for the moment uh thank you
um
so positives and negatives there let's
pause for a moment
and look at the impact of the black
lives matter movement now
well it began as we know in the united
states six years ago
as a response to police brutality since
then the slogan has
been used in demonstrations across the
world including
including here in the uk i'm joined
tonight by blm uk spokesperson
dr adam elliott cooper thanks very much
for
joining us this evening first of all
tell us who and what
blm uk is the acronym stands for black
liberation uh movement um you were a
part of black lives matter explain who
you are and what you're
you're hoping to achieve we're still uh
working under the name black lives
matter but we've had to register as a
community benefit society
um and so uh the available name uh to us
was
black liberation movements but we're a
network of activists across
uh england who have been doing
organizing work doing educational
projects
doing organizing rallies and protests
for a number of years now
to champion black lives and champion
racial equality across this country
and what what exactly would you say your
aims and objectives are because
people have been unclear about who black
lives matter
is as an organization is it political or
is it an
aspirational sentiment so
there are black lives matter
organizations all over the country um
particularly after the pro
the protests of this summer we've seen
black lives matter organizations set up
in every single town and city across the
country and people have different
interpretations
of what black lives matters means to
them but us as in uk blm we have a
number of different
um demands which relates to uh wanting
to radically reform the criminal justice
system
wanting to challenge climate and
environmental
catastrophe wanting to reform our
educational system and our welfare
system
and our employment and economy a whole
host of
issues that don't that go beyond
questions of police brutality that
brought people to the streets
of countries like britain earlier in
this year uh what about criticism that
the actual black lives matter movement
has been more divisive that than
anything else and actually has
has made uh race uh an issue and a
problem
that many people hadn't seen before
i think it's really interesting that you
say that because um
in the in the process of this summer we
saw not only black lives matter protests
in big towns and cities that have had
long histories of anti-racist struggle
but we saw black lives matter
mobilizations in tiny towns and villages
that have never seen such kinds
of protests even in the shetland islands
or the isle of wight we saw these types
of things i think it's difficult for
anyone
who's invested in anti-racism to not be
moved by these kinds of protests
and so i think that for some people who
might have been slightly blissfully
unaware
of the kinds of injustices that existed
in this country they may have
thought that black lives matter protests
bringing these issues into sharp relief
were actually bringing about the racial
tensions in the first place but that was
that isn't the case
they're simply highlighting and
illustrating an already existing issue
because we're not going to be able to
deal with it unless we're all aware of
it
and can and can all work together to try
to make the changes that this country so
desperately needs thank you
very much for your contribution there dr
adam elliott cooper the spokesperson for
blm
uk and what success looks like for his
organization and their aims and
objectives well let's see what the
audience think now um do you think
that the black lives matter movement has
helped or hindered the fight for
equality a show of hands please
so how are we looking there
uh quite quite a lot of you have raised
your
your hands there okay probably about
90 thank you very much audience
well let's take a look at the era of
criminal justice now
after george floyd was killed back in
may one of the most senior
black female officers in the country
described to sky news the unique
pain of watching the moments leading up
to his death
this week we went back to detective
chief inspector karen getters
and asked whether there have been any
concrete changes in british policing
since then we're still underrepresented
within policing around recruitment
there's still a disproportionality
around stop and search that's not going
to go away in six months
and we have to be realistic around that
so
there might not have been any concrete
changes that i can put my hat on and say
recruitment has gone up
stop and search statistics have changed
but what we have are plans now in place
both locally
and nationally and an appetite from
national police chief leaders as well
to do something concrete that has
longevity and legacy
linked to the murder of george floyd
detective chief inspector karen geddes
from west midlands police there saying
that
things won't happen overnight but
pointing to a change in
attitudes from police chiefs uh
alexandra your experience as a junior
criminal barrister it's very relevant
here
you were mistaken uh as we've said for a
suspect
three times uh when attending court in
one
single day how do you think bias plays
into how black people are treated
in the criminal justice system never
mind the the lawyers
i think bias has a huge role i think
black people are over criminalized
throughout the system
i think that they are over criminalized
as was already touched on by
um the officer that just spoke
from stop and search on the street level
you know black people are
38 per thousand black people are stopped
in search
compared to just four pair of thousand
white people so that's over nine times
as often
if you're black black people are more
likely to be arrested
they're more than three times as likely
to be arrested than their white
counterparts
when you get to the magistrates court
which is where i do a lot of my work
of course we see a disproportionate
number of black people and it's the same
in the crown court where i do work
black people are more likely to be given
a custodial sentence for the same
offences they're more likely to be sent
to prison they're more likely to receive
longer sentences
and then it's hardly surprising that we
look at prisons and black people are
over represented in prisons
they make up 12 around 12 percent of the
prison population
that's black people not bme black people
and
black people only make up about three or
four percent of our population
so they're hugely overrepresented in
prisons too
so there is a huge bias throughout our
system
where black people are constantly over
criminalized
i was doing another talk earlier today
and i flagged that the metropolitan
police
have a gang matrix a database where they
are
supposed to identify um gang members
78 of people on the gang matrix are
black
78 are black and
amnesty international have done multiple
reports on this gang matrix
and said that what these officers are
actually doing when they're identifying
potential gang members is using
cultural indicators that are often
associated with the black community
and in my experience that's what's
happening throughout the criminal
justice system
patrick tell us about your experiences
because you've been
stopped in by police i think it's that
the figure is astounding 30 times
in one week
yes when i was a young man in my 20s
i was stopped uh yeah almost
about 30 times and what happened was i
was stopped twice in a in a day i'd had
a nice new car a renault 5gt turbo i was
really proud of it
and i got stopped a couple of times and
the third stoppage i lost my
my rag and i you know had to go at the
officer
and he laughed at me and said i'm going
to show you what being stopped is really
like
and i had no idea what he was talking
about at the time
and then it dawned on me an hour later i
got stopped and then a half an hour
after that i got stopped again
it dawned on me that he had radioed in
my registration number
and told all these fellows officers you
know throughout that week make sure you
stop this man
and i got stopped about 30 times in one
week
this is 30 years ago but but still a
phenomenal
number of uh times to be stopped by the
police in one week well a member of
tonight's
audience works on the front line for the
metropolitan police ali hassan
ali how do you evaluate the relationship
between the police and the black
community
uh first of all thank you for having me
jillian um
i see this every single day and it's
it's difficult you know it's
sentiment at the moment people do want
to see change i'm one of those people
who joined the police to uh
be part of the solution um in my
day-to-day policing of course
people want to see people like myself
from the somali community from the black
community who
are front line officers uh joining the
police and uh
you know there's wonderful teams behind
the scenes that are doing this uh
recruitment uh level and getting these
um
officers in um the way i find the
sentiment at the moment is that
yes there's a major distrust and i think
it's generational
uh distrust um but again it's it takes
people like myself who joined the police
for this exact reason to build bridges
and
and speak to young boys on the streets
and this is what i do every single day
you know um
sometimes i just spend a lot of time
just discussing
what their views are about the police
and and sometimes we meet in the middle
of sometimes we don't but
again if i don't do it then who else
would do it you know
ali thank you very much let's um put
that to
simon um ali there talking about the the
generational mistrust
how do we break that cycle
in terms of the relationship with the
police
well i think we've got to have honest
conversations uh i think alexandra
highlighted this prejudice that
they see a young black man and they see
a criminal they don't see a lawyer a
barrister or a scientist
they see a potential criminal and of
course the other
big conversation we need is around drugs
policy
when we see who takes drugs actually
many people take drugs predominantly
white people
and yet seventy percent of stop and
searches for black people is drugs
related
and then it becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy if you keep stopping people for
drugs then you're gonna
you that is to be inevitable that you'll
find
some with drugs and then you say that
you have a drug spot
uh area so first of all it's an honest
conversation
too i would say that certain drugs that
they're stopping people for
for marijuana we need to say to yourself
well
a lot of people are taking this first of
all stop uh
having this focus just towards black
people but two
secondly let's have a honest
conversation about drugs
and say is this a priority or should we
be focusing on this
that way that we use police resources as
ali said
to move in the right direction look i'm
also part of recruiting
black and asian minority ethnic officers
with police now
but i want policing with consent i want
a representative police force and i want
all police officers
to stop this racial profiling
of many many innocent black people
lord willie thank you very much for that
uh contribution let's move on now
to the most up-to-date assessment of
race and inequality in the uk published
early this month
by the joint parliamentary committee on
human rights
it found that 64 percent of black people
in the uk do not believe
their health is as equally protected by
the nhs compared to white people
and 76 percent don't think their human
rights
are equally protected senior labour mp
harriet harman chairs that committee
here's her take on what needs to happen
now everybody believes
that society works better as well as it
being right for individuals
that people are on an equal footing and
there's no discrimination
so everybody agrees that and yet
nothing changes and this is just because
institutions and societies are slow to
change
unless those in power who are in
privileged positions
all of them turn their face against the
status quo
um and are no longer condoning and
really just
accepting uh unfairness
harriet harman mp who's chair of the
joint committee on human
rights we're staying with political
action we have a question
from our audience from um sophia osman
who's a student at lillian bayless
technology school
in kennington south london uh welcome to
you what's your question
hi i have a question from the attend
from my school
and i feel like it's very important to
recognize what the youth have to say
because they recognize
things that other people wouldn't see as
oblivious
and their question was how come the
government haven't taken any evil action
to support change in regards to racial
equality
thank you very much for that question
why has there been no real uh action
there i think i can summarize that point
we know that the official government
report from the commission on race
and ethnic disparities will be published
early next year but simon wooley
you've worked within government to
address racism
at that position you had until last year
what needs to happen
to make sure we don't have another
series of recommendations which are
never
implemented well we need action now
i think chichi said that there's been a
number of race equality reviews
and part of them david lammery review
the ruby mcgregor review
for ethnic minority paycat reporting
let's implement them now
let's act now people don't need to be
surveyed anymore look central to this is
political will
and if you have those in very very
powerful places
that are sometimes in denial of the
depth and scale of this we have a
problem
i think even worse than that that what
i'm seeing in some areas of politics
within central government there are some
that are pitting
the efforts of anti-racism as being
anti-white and anti-working-class boys
nothing could be further from the truth
and to and to pit one against the other
in that fashion to me is deplorable
look we have an opportunity to move the
dial but it needs political will
from the top from the center and right
away across the piece
and everybody wins by the way
nodding uh there is is there the
political will
in your estimation i'm not seeing it i'm
afraid and of course you know there's
this is
there's this incredible sense of um
people fearing to give up power because
they're
it's connected to giving up wealth or
something
and and but we all know that if if power
and thing
and wealth is shared it's a
it's a perceived fear because if we all
know if if it's shared
more equally then everyone benefits you
know
and unless we have a proper change of
attitude
at every level in society and
consistent re-education of everyone
including those
in power um increased representation of
minorities in positions of power
and influence um will it
otherwise it's just going to remain um a
mythical ideal
and the equal opportunities initiatives
of the woke
white liberal 1980s have failed
we it's time we moved to proportional
positive discrimination
decolonizing the curriculum is step
number one and when people constantly
it's one of the things i said in my
letter to the prime minister
the first point i make made was about
decolonizing
the curriculum and people keep saying to
me what gigi why do you want to change
history
i don't want to change history i think
we all deserve to know
the truth of history let's all get more
educated
and i think we'll all have a much fairer
and and
more under better understanding of each
other
patrick is that an area that you think
uh needs addressing um
you've taken a role in in setting up an
organization looking at
education of young black people is that
an area that needs
addressing that everybody is taught our
entire history the entirety of of
history is a starting point
you mentioned mentioning they're
decolonizing the curriculum
yes yeah i totally agree with chichi i
feel like um
i don't even think it should be black
history it should be we should be part
of history
so when they're teaching history our
history is included within that we
shouldn't have any
separate lessons for black history per
se we just need to be part of the main
curriculum
and and that's it okay let's go to back
to the audience now um denise
richards you're a campaigner you've
contributed to the government's equality
strategy you did that 10 years ago
how much do you think has changed since
then
and what can we learn this time around
well on paper the equalities act looked
impressive
but it's been the implementation of it
within their own policy framework
that's resulted in the continual failure
of black britons
because we're literally under a
government that has been has
not been able to respond adequately to
our problems
with meaningful or enforceable solutions
and it was actually designed by people
who actually don't even look like me
so the gravitational move required to
implement change has been so slow
and as a result the struggle in all the
key areas
remain as acute as ever health education
policing and the fair distribution of
opportunity generally
julian's solution well recognizing the
impact of capacity or
white privilege would be a great place
for white society to begin in accepting
that
sadly that this is still our reality 10
years on
so a downbeat assessment from denise
richards there about what's changed
since the government launched its
equality strategy 10
years ago so how do we
change that let's focus on solutions now
we've heard so far what's been done in
sport and in business and i'm going to
ask a
member of the panel the two concrete
things which they believe
must feature in that government report
on racial disparity which is due to be
published early next year
um i'll give you uh each around 40
seconds uh we're timing you to you first
of all
alexandra
thank you for not giving me 40 seconds
so and in terms of solutions and
what i'd like to see i think that we do
need to have more targets i think
we need to set targets and there needs
to be consequences
if targets aren't met i think that's the
first thing
that's super important and then i think
the the second thing
is the curriculum i echo what chi chi's
already said
i didn't even know much about my own
history until i got to university
and actively looked into it and i think
that we have a right to know black
british people
are british people and so black british
history should be part of the curriculum
patrick um i think i would like to see
some sort of uh an offstead for
corporations where
you know they have to uh prove
what they've done for inclusion and
diversity and be held accountable
and named and shamed if they haven't uh
shown improvements in those areas
and also you know running back to the
criminal justice system i would really
like to see
the marijuana issue revisited because
the criminal
criminalization of black men is going on
for too long
and it's okay if you're uh you know
you're drunk
inebriated you know urinating on
yourself and shouting profanities that
passes by because
of drinking alcohol that's okay but
people that
uh you know partaking marihuana are
criminalized
and going to prison so i don't know
that's unfair as far as i'm concerned
chichi your two solutions please
um well first of all i just want to say
agreeing with patrick about the offstage
and i want to call it
bofstead and and i think we could we
know what the b
stands for capital b so hugely increased
representation of minorities
uh in minority communities on all
employment panels
police accountability panels race
equality committees
and educational development development
forums
we're no longer prepared to listen to or
accept
recommendations of majority white
decision-making processes and
then i'd like to move on to saying that
we need to
reimburse all african caribbean
employees and retired workers the tax
contributions that they've made of their
working lives
that were paid in compensation to
families
of dispossessed slave owning families
that's a very controversial one there
chichi but one that has been mentioned
before uh lord simon wooley your two
solutions please
first of all the 12 recent race equality
reviews
implement the recommendations they're on
the shelf
implement them deliver them secondly
covered 19 has laid bare many structural
inequalities
in education in health in housing in
criminal justice
the government could put together a
covet 19
race equality strategy and cover
those broad central issues
if they had that they'd have a plan
short and sweet thank you panel before
we wrap up a final show of hands from
the audience
how many of you believe that the
suggested solutions that you've had
tonight could
really affect change
lots of hands going up anybody still
undecided
uh how many do we think now
how many do we think have hands up now
95 percent of you
uh thank you very much well that's it
for tonight
thanks to all in our virtual audience
for your questions and your thoughts
thanks to to our panelists
alexandra wilson patrick hutchinson
chichi wanaku
and lord simon wooley over the past hour
we've heard about the strategies already
being put into place to help eradicate
racism particularly in sport and in
business
and those which still need to be
implemented we've talked about the
ethnicity pay gap
and making it cvs anonymous we've also
spoken about making it clearer that
diversity is in
everyone's interests we're no longer to
accept just recommendations
one of our panelists said we need
compensation for slavery
thank you for watching good night